NEIL: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, MY
FRIEND, MARK MEREDITH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, WANT TO GO TO
SENATOR MIKE BRAUN IN THE MIDDLE
OF ALL OF THIS THE INDIANA
REPUBLICAN JOINS US ON THE PHONE
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME.
WELL THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR
AS YOU KNOW AND YOUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES MADE IT CLEAR THAT
DESPITE THE STRENGTH IN THAT
EMPLOYMENT REPORT, AND THAT WE
DON’T NEED THIS , THAT THEY WANT
THIS , AND THEY WILL LIKELY GET
THIS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> WELL THEY ARE DEFINITELY
GOING TO GET IT AND I’M
LITERALLY HERE THE LAST THREE TO
FOUR VOTES WE’VE BEEN UP ALL
NIGHT AND THE ONLY
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC BE WHAT YOU HEARD, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT WILL BE
AT $300 AND WILL GO THROUGH
SEPTEMBER, BUT NEIL, IF YOU
WOULD LOOK INTO THE AMENDMENT
THAT WE OFFERED TO FLUSH OUT
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT IS IN
THIS BILL, BECAUSE 90% OF IT
UNRELATED TO COVID, AND THERE
WAS ONE ITEM THAT WAS JUST A
SMALL AMOUNT IN TODAY’S
DENOMINATION, 390 MILLION WAS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE UNDERLYING
AUTHORIZATION OF 70 MILLION FOR
THE  SBA AND THERE WAS A
GROUP OF AG LOANS THAT WERE NOT
ONLY FORGIVEN BY ETHNICITY, BUT
GIVEN A 20% DIVIDEND, TO BOOT,
AND THAT KIND OF STUFF, WHEN I
THINK PEOPLE LOOK INTO WHAT’S IN
IT, THAT WISH LIST THAT WE’VE
HEARD ABOUT THAT’S BEEN RUSHED
OVER HERE, WE’VE TRIED TO FLUSH
IT OUT WITH ROUGHLY 25-30
AMENDMENTS BUT THERE’S MORE THAN
YOU CAN IMAGINE TOTALLY
UNRELATED, TWO COVID RELIEFS AND
THE HEALTHCARE ISSUE, ECONOMIES
REBOUNDING BACK IN THE STATES
THAT HAD GOOD BUSINESS CLIMATES
AND DIDN’T HAVE THESE MASSIVE
SHUTDOWNS IN RELATION TO
THE DISEASE ITSELF, AND I THINK
WE DO SEE IT STARTING TO TICK UP
IT’S STEADY OVER THE NEXT YEAR
OR  TWO, AND WHAT DO WE HAVE, 5%
PREDICTED GDP GROWTH FOR THE
FIRST QUARTER AND I
DON’T NEED TO EXPLAIN WHAT THAT
MEANS WHEN IT COMES TO INFLATION
AND THAT IT’S SIMPLY NOT NEEDED,
WE’RE BORROWING EVERY PENNY OF
IT TO BOOT.
NEIL: WELL THAT’S NOTHING NEW TO
YOUR POINT, SENATOR.
I DO WONDER THOUGH, AND THE
DEMOCRATS WITH WHOM I’VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS VERY
SUBJECT, SENATOR HAVE BEEN
SAYING, WELL, REPUBLICANS ARE
FINE ONES TO TALK ABOUT THE
DEFICITS GETTING WORSE, DEBT
BUILDING, YOU KNOW, IT WAS A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP WHO URGED DURING THE FALL
TO GO BIG AND A BIGGER STIMULUS
PLAN BE BETTER THAN ANYTHING
SMALLER.
IN FACT, HIS WISHES WERE
SOMETHING MORE IN TOTAL THAN
THIS , AT THE TIME.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER THAT, THAT IT
WAS FINE FOR DONALD TRUMP EVEN
THOUGHING BIGGER BACK THEN, NOT
NOW.
>> WELL, I THINK FIRST OF ALL,
HE WAS DOING IT NOT TO MAKE ANY
EXCUSE FOR HOW MUCH OR  WHEN IT
WAS TOO MUCH, SO WE WERE NOT
WHERE WE COULD SEE THE TANGIBLE
EVIDENCE THAT WE GOT ON THE RUN
AND WE DID ROUGHLY 4 TRILLION
BIPARTISAN SO IT WAS THE FIVE
BILLS PRIOR HAD 90 VOTES PLUS ON
EACH OF THE FIVE, AND I THINK
THAT YOU COULD MAKE THE CASE IN
GENERAL THOUGH, THIS PLACE RUNS
WITH TRILLION DOLLARS STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS RELATED MOSTLY TO
SOCIAL SECURITY AND THERE ARE
ONLY FOUR OR  FIVE OF IT, NEIL,
THAT GO IN WAYS THAT WOULD SHOW
IT.
THAT’S A PROBLEM THAT PRECEDED
TRUMP.
DON’T KNOW WHETHER HIS FORTE WAS
BEING A FISCAL CONSERVATIVE AND
THAT HAD TO BE SHOWN YET, BUT
THERE’S NO DOUBT ABOUT THIS ,
AND MOST OF IT COMES FROM THE
HOUSE.
THE SENATE, ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, DIDN’T ADD AS MUCH TO IT
AS I IMAGINED AND MOST OF IT
CAME OVER FROM THE HOUSE, WHICH
THEY AREN’T GOING TO CHANGE, AND
I THINK WHAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
NEEDS TO DO IS LOOK INTO THE
DETAILS OF WHAT’S IN THE
BILL, IN THOSE COMMITTEES
THAT GOT RUSHED OVER HERE AND
THANK GOODNESS RON JOHNSON AND E
LISE DAVIS LOOKED AT IT AND
THEN FOR IT TO BE READ OUTLOUD,
AND THEN THE 11-HOUR DELAY WAS
PLANNING TO GET THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AT 300 BUCKS.
NEIL: OKAY, WE’LL WATCH IT VERY
CLOSELY, SENATOR I KNOW YOU’RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF THAT AND
THIS VOTE-O-RAMA WILL GO ON BUT
A VOTE LOOKS LIKE TO YOUR POINT